from the studio who brought you
ratatouille wall-e and up comes the
movie that paid for all of them toys I
mean cars cruise into Radiator Springs a
town full of fun friends and adventure
just don't ask where all the humans are
because we're either extinct murdered by
our cars or we merge with them to become
some kind of unholy man car hybrid hmm
probably shouldn't think too hard about
that moving on
Pixar built an empire at a beautiful
emotionally real tightly plotted
masterpieces and cars is almost all of
those things as this above average Kids
movie never reaches Pixar's highest
highs but it's better than people give
it credit for I mean you know it's not
flawless lightning is kind of a jerk it
looks awful now matches the rest of the
town the catchphrases are kind of
annoying
I guess we really don't have that much
to say about the first Cars movie can we
just do cars too instead that's better
from the studio who brought you
ratatouille wall-e and up comes a
tedious cash-grab dumpster fire that's
Pixar's worst movie by a long shot
Cars 2
you like cars well enough but since your
kids loved it Pixar's going full minions
and making a sequel about the side
character they can relate to because
kids are dumb this is your fault parents
why didn't you just buy them more
ratatouille merchandise oh you remember
lightning Sally and the rest of the gang
at regular Springs
we'll forget about them because it's
mater's time to shine spend way too long
with this annoying southern truck played
by non southern comedian Daniel Whitney
who pretends to be a dumb hick named
Larry the Cable Guy who pretends to be
this book tooth truck version of Larry
the Cable Guy it's like a turducken of
fake idiots pretending to be even bigger
faker idiots after lightning simple
story of learning to slow down and
appreciate life get ready for a
confusing plot about a car it creates an
alternative fuel just to make
alternative fuel look bad but no amount
of logic will stop mater from visiting
as many playsets and accessories as
possible no matter how many force
misunderstandings it takes to get there
you know I'm just a tow truck right
right and I'm just in the import-export
business he just told you he's not a spy
my line of work is throwing a job right
and miss chip wells is designing the
iPhone apps really again agent
you mean like insurance
see he's not a spy tell you that Oh
time why is no one listening to him so
buckle up for a movie responsible for
some of Pixar's firsts like their first
sequel to stretch a thin comic relief
character into a whole movie first time
they weren't nominated for a Best
Animated Feature Oscar and the first
time they went full-blown rotten on
Rotten Tomatoes
or is this more or less a Rotten
Tomatoes I mean do they even have
tomatoes in Carl's world I guess they
must eat food because they have those
giant tongues but it seems like all they
do is just drink gas unless gasses their
blood except Mayor mistakes with sabe
for ice cream which means they have ice
cream but the cows in this universe are
tractors so do they like milk the
tractors
does your car model determine your
species your class your ethnicity like
your cop cars have to be cops there can
a race car be a janitor if he wants to
and how our cars born this car is a mom
my mama is that idea what's the
difference between boy and girl cars the
cars have sex how our headlights boobs
and had a car's die if they keep
replacing their parts are they like
immortal there's a car pope so is their
car thoughtless ism what kind of car was
Jesus Sarge is a veteran which means
there were car wars was he in car Nam
and the car was Hitler is the engine the
brain of the heart what's the difference
between a doctor and a mechanic if they
opened their door to other guts fall out
white of course even have door handles
in a world with no humans driving them
except this car has eyes and her
headlights and a steering wheel in seats
oh cheese they did kill us all they just
evolved and covered it off damn you
dirty brakes damn you all to hell oh wow
yeah really sidetracked there where was
I again oh yeah story cars
money then NASCAR is really boring
despite the negative press coffee fair
the Sun is a deadly laser licking
doorknobs is illegal on other planets
use the Force Katniss to save hogwarts
from the Daleks
they call me mr. pig